[Music]
[Applause]
spring in Bill Michael's host of the
bill Michael show on
w-o-t-e-am the franchise in Green Bay
and uh on from 10 to 2 on our Green Bay
affiliate he joins us now Packer is
going to play hardball here bill
I don't think they're going to play
hardball I think they're going to try to
you know remember it was a couple years
ago when Aaron talked about how veteran
players were treated and and he kind of
you know put the the organization on
notice so I don't think they're going to
try to look bad in this I think they're
going to try to get everything they
possibly can for Aaron Rodgers if that
means one or two ones or what have you
they're going to try to do that because
you just don't want to let him walk away
but you know I go back to something that
Brian goodekin said at the end of the
season press conference when he had
stated two things that stuck out to me
one was when they signed this contract
with Aaron Rodgers they weren't in it
for one year and then the next thing he
said after that is they expect a certain
level of return on their investment so I
think whether that's level of play
that's commitment or you know getting
the most of what they can for him at
this point I think that's what they're
going to do but I expected to get done
relatively soon I mean everybody here is
waiting for uh an announcement from the
Packers and then obviously the uh the
press conference there afterward Brian
goodekin's and or Mark Murphy what was
the local reaction on your radio show
it's kind of split uh there's a lot of
people that are just tired of the drama
we went through you know this with Brett
Favre and I I worked with Brett Favre's
dad uh for a long time so I kind of knew
a little bit more on the inside and we
went through this back and forth for
years with larv and farv kind of got
addicted to coming back into Green Bay
and getting the cheers and the adulation
and then eventually Ted Thompson just
said we've got a guy we don't need you
anymore we'll talk to you later and kind
of forced Brett's hand I think and I
said in both cases because I did a sit
down with five years ago and I think in
both in both cases if both quarterbacks
say at the end of the season I'm going
to take a little time and when I come
back I'm all in I think that forces the
organization to take you you know you
you close your own door is what farv
told me and farb said that had he just
said look I'm all in I'm ready to go I
want to come back I want to work hard I
want to run this back one more time and
try to win a championship the Packers
have no choice but to take you back same
thing with Aaron Rodgers if he you know
contemplating retirement but comes out
and says look I'm all in I want to work
with Christian Watson I want to work
with Romeo Dobbs I'm there let's do this
then the Packers have no choice but to
take them back they would run it back
with him but I think what they were
looking for was a certain level of
commitment and when they didn't get it
they said okay it's time to move on
well you know in in with Aaron you're
never quite sure there's passive
aggressive and he is kind of you know
like a a subtle dig or not so subtle dig
about lack of communication and I you
know but then they did give him this
guaranteed contract they wanted you to
be in he wasn't all in
so I understand the Packers side of this
but
are they all in on Jordan love I think
is really the most important part of all
of this from the Green Bay Side of
things I think that there's a lot of
people that hope I think they're walking
around saying that he's ready and you
only you're only going to find out if
he's a winner or not a winner uh which
is another thing that Brian goodekin
said by putting him out there
um you know I had a really interesting
conversation with Charles Woodson years
ago and then we kind of reignited that
this past year at Super Bowl and I'd
asked Charles I said you know tell me
about this Rogers guy years ago and he
said man this guy's eating us up he said
he's running scout team and he's killing
us this guy's for real and so I talked
to Charles about that and reminded him
of that and he said go ask jair
Alexander go ask Adrian Amos go ask them
if don't ask you know your offensive
guys because your guys are going to
stick together he said go ask your
defensive guys if Jordan love is ready
to go and you get that you know hey is
Jordan love ready to go and they go yeah
you know it there's not that oh my God
that he's ready to go so I think I I
think we've all seen it we saw a game
and which Kansas City prepared for him
and he didn't fare very well we saw a
game in which the second half against
Detroit they prepared for him he didn't
fare very well and then when the Eagles
did not prepare for him and they were
playing kind of a an off-press defense
because they had a pretty sizable lead
at the time he lit him up for you know
nine passes in two series and and looked
pretty good so uh it's what have you
done for me lately and that's what
Packers fans are banking on was that
that's the level of Jordan love that
we're gonna get and you know you know as
well as I do if you don't have a top
five defense around a guy who's a
relatively average or above average
Quarterback you're not going to go deep
into the postseason so I think that's
what they need to focus on and get him a
few more weapons and then we'll see yeah
and Rogers with the Jets when you
protect him he's great
plain and simple you protect him he's
going to be awesome there and I think
Shoring up the offensive line but what
you've seen with Rogers and he didn't
have a great year last year but still in
comparison to other quarterbacks they
would take the year that Rogers had in a
down year what do you expect for him
let's say the next let's say he plays
two years with the Jazz I expect him if
you if you know Aaron he will come back
with a vengeance he will do anything and
everything he possibly can to make this
work to make he he wears chips on his
shoulder outwardly and he will come back
and I don't doubt that he could have an
MVP type of season uh but what I saw
from the very beginning when the
contract was signed what they wanted was
Aaron's coming in he's not here with
Devonte he needs to work with these
young guys and whether it's on the field
or off the field you just need to build
a relationship you know Romeo Dobbs
wasn't trying to take a stab at him when
he was asked honestly what's it like to
hang out with Aaron Rodgers because he
didn't Rogers didn't hang out with them
and he didn't hang out with Aaron and
they didn't do anything away from the
place but it was all business when they
were there but there's a relationship
that needs to be built just ask Patrick
Mahomes who's now sitting at home with a
Lombardi trophy because he wanted to
work with his guys early now I'm not
saying that would have happened in Green
Bay but certainly you would have gotten
more I think out of this than what we
saw this past year and I don't think you
can ask Aaron to for so many years like
they did just drag you across the finish
line and let's see what happens I think
Aaron needs some help around him and
remember he's going into a situation
where forever he was always talking
about relationships with his receivers
and Trust well if he doesn't come in
early and he doesn't work with these
guys you're going to hear it fourth game
fifth game in well you know we don't
have that relationship I don't have that
trust yet we're working on this we're
working on that these are all things
that need to be accomplished early on
that that groundwork needs to be laid
early on and so you're going to see
where his level of commitment is to the
New York Jets much like the Packers
maybe either waited for or wanted to see
in Green Bay I brought this up yesterday
do the Jets want Aaron Rodgers more than
the Packers want to get rid of Aaron
Rodgers
yes I like I said I think if Aaron would
have said guys I'm all in man I I wasn't
sure but I'm ready to go there's Legacy
tied to this Dan uh remember Mark Murphy
has to retire in a couple of years
that's the codisil and the presidency
for the Green Bay Packers so when you
reach a certain age you must retire so
he's got Legacy on this he wanted
another championship and I think he
really wanted another championship with
Aaron Rodgers and Rogers had told me
years ago he said look if I win another
Super Bowl I will be the most decorated
Super Bowl era winner in Green Bay
history go back to even even Bart Starr
who got a couple of them but with the
records with the passing numbers and
then with two Super Bowls he he's by far
the best quarterback in Green Bay
Packers history that's what he wanted so
there was a lot of that want there it
was just the level of commitment to the
want is what they were hoping for
better Legacy Farr or Rogers in Green
Bay I think Florida went to two Super
Bowls and he also reignited titles in
title town and started all of this uh
look Lambeau Field does not get rebuilt
if it isn't for Brett Favre um you go
back to God love Bob Harlan and the
former president of the Green Bay
Packers I remember sitting with him
there uh the night that they were hoping
for the Brown County tax to get passed
and I said Bob what's Plan B he looked
at me with a Tyrion design said Bill
there is no plan B if we don't get this
we don't get a new stadium and we don't
know what we're going to do we'll
probably have to move and it was because
of Brett Favre the success of the
Packers Resurgence of the Packers that
all of this then come to fruition and
then the Legacy has since been extended
and now it is a you know a literal Taj
Mahal of of football it is Hallowed
Ground and and it'll stay there forever
but they were that close to leaving
Green Bay I believe great to talk to you
Bill thanks for joining appreciate it
thanks guys that's uh Bill Michael's
host of the bill Michael show on
w-o-t-e-a-m the franchise and uh our
local affiliate in Green Bay